[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and my spoiler sense is
tingling with these brand new spider-man
no way home leaks the movie is just over
a month away now and there were some big
images posted online the other day by
john campier that seemed to confirm some
of the major leaks on the movie we've
already done a full breakdown on them in
which we look closely at toby mcguire's
dick and that will be linked above right
now if you want to swing over there and
see what the images are everyone's
talking about them and even youtube yes
the actual youtube account for youtube
posted on my video saying juicy so you
just know the world wants to know what's
in this movie cambia ended up trending
and even though he deleted the tweets he
can't put the toothpaste back in the
tube on this stuff and the world is
gonna remember even if he goes to doctor
strange since then camp here has talked
about them on a live stream and in this
video we're gonna be breaking down what
he said and also why it actually
confirms the images were real the whole
thing was about 20 minutes long and it
covered how he got the images why he
thought it was cool to post them and
also what a certain studio that starts
with the letter s said we're going to be
getting into it in this video but if you
think they're real then please hit the
thumbs up button and if you don't then
click down but i think after we go
through it you'll see that one of them
is likely legitimate now i won't be
showing them in this video as i've
already put them in one and if sony
decide to strike that and then this one
then my channel is gonna go about as
well as eddie brock's career i can say
though that there are two images the
first of which is tom holland toby
maguire and andrew garfield and their
spider-man costumes standing on some
scaffolding several elements of this
line up with other leaks such as the
scaffolding floor and that video of
andrew grabbing onto a railing john said
when he got them he thought they were
fake so decided to post them and he
actually watermarked the images so it
was pretty clear that they came from him
he also gave the most hilarious leaked
breakdown comment i've ever heard and
this will go down in history and i can't
believe i'm about to say this i never
thought i would say this in my entire
online career
but look closely at toby maguire's dick
i never thought i would say that ever in
my life but here we are if you go and
look at the picture look closely at toby
maguire's balls now the other picture
john posted had peter may happy and matt
murdock all sitting around a table in
may's apartment this seemed to be a
scene that we've heard about in
interviews in which they all set about
discussing what it means to be a hero
now i really don't know if i believe
whether john thought they were fake or
not as i don't know why you would post
something that looked like it could be
real other than to get an exclusive
scoop john said he had nothing to gain
from it but then was also saying that
he'd gained 1 000 new followers and that
he watermarked them because the last
fake photo he posted got 12 000 retweets
and a lot of attention however let's
give him the benefit of the doubt and
say that he just posted them out without
thinking in the hopes of people
discussing how good of a photoshop they
were now what's interesting is that in
the interview john says that sony
contacted him and asked him to tell them
who sent the images i've leaked things
in the past and the only time that
studio ever got into contact with me was
when stuff turned out to be real what i
have done though is that i've kept my
mouth shut about it until the actual
thing released and then said yeah the
studio contacted me which is why i
haven't really addressed it again i
think it's kind of stupid for john to
admit that people from pr have been
getting in touch with him as that would
only ever happen if something was a
legitimate leak there's thousands and
thousands of photoshopped images
released online every single day and the
studio wouldn't bother paying someone to
follow up on each of these and ask
exactly why someone has made a picture
of the spiderman actors standing
together john said he didn't tell them
who his source was and i can definitely
say that it isn't my uncle who works in
the sony store in eldon square in
newcastle now by launching somewhat of
an investigation into where the leaks
came from you already know that at least
one of them has to be real now it is
possible that the other is fake and one
just happened to get bundled in with
some photoshop stuff john said that the
studio rep wouldn't confirm if things
were real or not and i do believe that
don campier seems like a bit of a wild
card as do all youtubers so i think the
best thing they could really do is just
keep things as ambiguous as possible now
personally i don't think that don
campier played things as well as he
should have and if it was me i would
have just not addressed it and hope that
the entire thing just blew over don
giovanni campier has kind of doubled
down and he said that he didn't even
post all of the pictures that he got
i got sent these pictures i thought they
were fake slapped my watermark on it so
i wanted credit for sharing them put
them up as soon as i heard that they
were they could be real i deleted them
immediately and i didn't even share all
the pictures
i didn't even share all the pictures
um should i give you a little tease
into what was one of the other pictures
that you'd never be able to deduce what
the actual image is
um i'll give you a little tease i'm
gonna give you a tease only because
you'll never actually guess or deduce
what the actual picture is
but it involves somebody in a mocap suit
so yeah i don't know it's just kind of a
weird way to go about it and the dawn of
spoilers it didn't even seem that
bothered by the issues that it could
cause with the studio you've got chad
campio out here saying he posted them
and has more and then you've got the
virgin kevin spoilers being like well i
can describe the images to you but i
don't want a copyright strike either way
this is a really bad thing to happen and
i can imagine the studio is trying to
find out what the other images are where
they came from and how many people have
seen them spider-man now at home trends
just about every single day on twitter
and it's probably going to be the
biggest movie this side of the pandemic
i know a lot of people think sony have
done really bad marketing for the movie
but when you're constantly going viral
off doing very little it actually seems
like it might be the best marketing
strategy from a business point of view
there's just so much hype around the
movie and it might actually be the first
one to cross the billiard mark so it's
clear that the studio will want to know
what else is out there if someone has
sent something to don or giovanni who
doesn't even spoil stuff then you can
imagine they probably sent them to more
people and it will no doubt be a worry
that more things will get out into the
open now i really don't think that
corleone campia should have said he has
more images as there will no doubt be
people hitting him up right now asking
what they are even just the mention of
there being a mocap suit has sent people
into a wild frenzy and i've had so many
people message me asking if i know who
it is if i was speculating i think the
most likely thing would be that it's tom
hardy playing venom in the movie but
there could be a number of things
perhaps jon doesn't know lizard is in
the movie and he saw that or thomas
hayden church and so on and so forth
i've even talked with people about how
it could be ant-may or happy in an iron
man costume and rather than quashing the
leaks campier has kind of added fuel to
the fire he does say in the video that
some leakers and scoopers would probably
step over their mother to get their
leaks which i don't actually agree with
as i stepped over mine to get them end
game leaks and she's not spoken to me
since now off the back of this i
actually got sent some leaked images of
the movie and i'm going to show them on
screen in just a bit i have watermarked
them as well but obviously i don't want
credit and i've got nothing to gain
drumroll please
[Music]
now if this studio get in touch it's
going to be pretty clear that they're
real as that's something that only
happens when a big league like this gets
out and they want to carry out an
investigation to see where it came from
grace randolph covered the topic as well
and she pretty much said the golden rule
is that you don't post the photo and
that's something i agree with as well in
my vids i always tend to downplay as
much as i actually know as the way that
leaks work is is that if you know
something with definite then you are
breaking the law by leaking it whereas
if you say it may or may not be true
it's covered by fair use it's a really
weird situation but i think the best
comparison i can make is say julian
assange said the moon was made out of
cheese that would be a big conspiracy
theory blown wide open and he would get
in a lot of trouble for it however if i
just reported that julian assange has
said the moon is made out of cheese i'd
be okay because i didn't actually leak
it and i'm just reporting on the leak
instead of being the person pushing it
to the public so yeah i don't know what
sony are going to do in all honesty
they've kind of been a bit light on
blocking videos and the andrew garfield
clip is all over youtube which i really
wouldn't expect in the past i got a
video block from warner brothers for
just talking about the theater only
tenant trailer whereas these guys are
letting entire clips and trailers be
released online i think them reaching
out to camp here confirms that at least
one image is legit though but let me
know below exactly what you think as a
thank you you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of november in
which we're giving away three copies of
the zack snyder dc trilogy all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
make the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the original images
which will be linked on screen right now
if you still haven't seen them and want
to know what they are then definitely go
head over there after this as it is
quite an interesting leak if not then
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul and you take care
yourself peace